Chris Sims from pro football talk live
joins us now top that Chris what is it
it's the best ending to a song but you
got a you got a perform it I don't know
if Richie gave you a heads up
probably not but no do you have a you
have a great ending to a song I can't
think of one right off the bat like
let's talk some football maybe something
will come to my mind that I'll end the
interview with something that comes to
my head okay all right that's a great
ending to the song that's all yeah a
great ending yeah yeah okay yeah because
most people talk about the beginning of
a song and I we focus on something
different when it was just how a song
ends that's well like right away I think
of like stairway to heaven like Led
Zeppelin how it like just goes into that
like huge moment there at the end where
all the sudden it becomes like an
unbelievable hard rock rock'n'roll song
where it was slow leading up to that so
that's one that jumped out to me I mean
I love me some stairway to heaven and
red LED death was definitely my favorite
class classic rock band so that's one
you're at you're preaching to the choir
there because it was always awkward at
the high school dances when stairway to
heaven came on because it starts out and
it's in my wheelhouse it's slow dancing
and then all of a sudden my arms aren't
around her anymore because you're not
you can't slow dance when it starts to
pick it up man then I got to go air
guitar guitar owner yeah that would pose
the problems that's good you know those
are for people who are you know dancing
at the problem in the 70s I didn't have
that process sorry all right here's your
question for you Chris Sims Pro Football
Talk NBC Sports the quarterback who
could benefit the most from a Super Bowl
win of the Final Four is who well I mean
I think that conversation is between
mahomes and Rodgers right off the bat
you know the thing I look at here I'm
gonna I think I'm Altima gonna say Aaron
Rodgers here obviously get me Patrick
mahomes I think this was catapult him
into ooh he has a chance to be really
really special and when a lot of Super
Bowls if he can do it in his second year
starting but he also has a
years left in his career to do this as
well where Rogers I think you know we
get down here we're getting were to the
end at least it's coming to the end
we're on the you know the slope down
downward and yeah he's only been to one
Super Bowl you know I know you know I I
hold them in very very high regard I
think anybody that's watched football
realizes he's certainly one of the
all-time greats and to get into the I've
been do as two Super Bowls and want to
and have a chance to win a second Super
Bowl I think our yeah brings him into a
different stratosphere and maybe
silences some of the haters of the world
who don't think Rogers as good as I do
or maybe some people around the NFL I
thought Ryan Tannehill has the most to
gain because he was forgotten he was a
backup a murder and maybe he's another
Nick Foles waiting to happen
Rodgers to me if he wins too now he goes
into a different stratosphere now you
can make a legitimate argument that he's
the second best quarterback of all time
you know Brady is still gonna be number
one but he he would at least be in the
conversation even though he got guys who
have more Super Bowls than him
I think mahomes winning one would put
him into the russell wilson category of
young quarterback Jimmy Garoppolo would
be in that too Jimmy Garoppolo would be
more like Russell Wilson because you
know it's a defensive minded team that
he's on he's not necessarily asked to be
the star at least Russ wasn't back then
he is now but I see grandpa maybe a
parallel to become Russell Wilson if he
would win the Super Bowl yeah I could
see that certainly I mean you know hey
don't win a Super Bowl early in your
career you know you look at you look at
the guys or you know consider the
all-time greats
they all did that you know whether
that's Montana Brady Terry Bradshaw
Russel Wilson
it is a huge thing and you know you
might say well why is it so amused
because it takes the pressure off the
situation if you're that franchise
quarterback right you know just go bed I
proved it in year two or three I played
in the hardest situation circumstance
you could possibly play so from there on
out you got the confidence one to go
okay I've already known I passed the
toughest test and you know the NFL which
is winning a Super Bowl so it doesn't
get any harder than that and then also
it gives you an awesome freedom as a
young player because you go yeah I've
already bought it so I can let it fly
the next time I'm in an AFC Championship
game and not worry about like oh gosh I
got to protect the ball in my legacy and
I got to try to get to the Super Bowl
and I think those are great advantages
of for the quarterbacks who do win it at
an early stage you know I mean none of
them are wrong you're right and
Tannehill I think is above Nick Foles as
far as to your point like yeah maybe
it's that story but I think he's got
more talent than Nick Foles I mean I
think tena Hill is a borderline
franchise type guy I think Tennessee
seeing that and I'm kind of be surprised
if they don't sign him there's some sort
of long-term deal after this year is
over no matter what happens this weekend
on Sunday he's Chris Sims from pro
football talk live you can see him every
morning Monday through Friday with Mike
Florio have you seen enough of Joe
burrow where and you've always been
cutting edge ahead a lot of people you
or had a lot of people with Lamar
Jackson is Joe burrow a sure thing I you
know I do I think he is a sure thing
yes now does he have like this
incredible right arm like a Patrick
mahomes or you know the legs of a Lamar
Jackson or anything like that no he
doesn't have that one thing I look at
just go oh my gosh that is so
extraordinary there's no way he can fail
but the one thing I look at is I don't
really see any weakness in his game I
think that's the thing that jumps out to
me more than anything where I go okay
good sighs Wow
really good athlete like better than you
would expect the way he moves around it
when a lane opens up he can go rip off a
30-yard run like we saw the other night
at the end of the first half against
Clemson the throwing it's really good
he's got a real good arm
is it a mahomes Aaron Rodgers type arm
no it's not but it's really good that
way he's executed a pro-style offense
yes he's had some big-time pros around
him I get that but there's other top 10
picks over quarterbacks that had
big-time Cal around them as well and you
know he's got tremendous feel
I did I mean that's the one thing he
just got a he knows how to place the
ball in certain situations he never
really came to throw the ball into
coverage he moves around in the pocket
and never seen flustered but yet can
keep his eyes downfield that's where
I've really impressed with him he really
knows how to play the position let alone
he's got you know some big-time talent
to go along with it
but we're also seeing this trend Cuyler
Murray we got a one-year sample with him
Dwayne Haskins a one-year sample Joe
Burrell basically a one-year sample the
previous year I mean he had good numbers
but nothing like this yes I mean how
tough is that for the scouts to be able
you know Trevor Lawrence is going to
give you three years of a sample size
yeah no no it's tough there you're right
I mean hey you want you want the sample
size more than anything you want the
reps that's the big thing you know at
least Joe Broz got that the last two
years we just got a number of throws and
big plays and big moments and he played
in the SEC and you know the SEC is the
closest thing in college football to the
NFL it's just you know every defense has
NFL demons alignment and linebackers and
corners and all those things so you've
been able to measure that you know I
think he's played enough to where that's
not going to be an issue if it was just
this year yeah I can understand that
question because then you start to get
into Mitchell true Biscay conversation
and things like that where you go yeah
okay he was good but you know does he
have a real good feel of the game as he
nuance that the position things like
that but I think I've seen enough from
Joe and I think he's a tough prep set
and I saw evaluators will feel good
about what they see over the last few
years and especially this year most
important on quarterback playing this
weekend is who oh well it's hard not the
point at Derrick Henry I mean I just
look at I look at that game and I expect
the Kansas City Chiefs to win I do you
know I watched the first game back
earlier this week on film Kansas City
was very close early in the game to
really blowing the Tennessee Titans out
of the football game but I mean and the
Chiefs are better on run defense one of
the better run defenses in football
down the stretch really ever since that
game and weekend but man this offensive
line for the Titans you know I just
wonder you know am I being a fool is
this is another matchup where it just
doesn't matter and this office alive but
they're their first round cats for top
ten tackles and good guard play and
center play are they just gonna mash
this ball once again with this big you
know dump truck Derrick Henry and it's
gonna be five yards they're gonna be
eight yards and it's going to be five
yards it's gonna be 50 yards III think
that Kansas City has the right team and
people to slow down that attack let
alone hopefully they're you know at
least in my opinion their offense could
put pressure on the Tennessee offense if
the Chiefs can get out and get a lead
and everything like that but man Derrick
Henry is is that as important of a
running back as I see to a team at a
long long time alright so who do you
have for the games both of them you're
saying are you for that yeah I'm gonna
go Chiefs 31:20 alright and I'm gonna go
49ers 24 to 17 to win that game I think
that I think the 49ers are the best team
left you know as you saw last week
though Jimmy G is scary
he's scary there's no doubt about that
you know he he could have easily thrown
four or five interceptions of that game
last week well what concerns you because
I've said that all along I might be the
last guy in with Jimmy G I'm just
waiting when he needs to make a big play
can he make a big play I think he's
helped out you know he's surrounded by
you know very good defense secondary and
they've got a really good offensive line
and running game yep he might forced to
you know at some point make a big play
and that's what I want to see I know
you're right I mean he's answered a lot
of the questions you know hey he made
some big plays in New Orleans right so
in that game you of course week 17 up in
Seattle and he played maybe his best
game of the year but yeah the question
still remains and this is playoff
football as we know it's different you
know the players go for broke more
defensive coordinators go for broke if
I'm Green Bay and I'm Mike Pettine the
defensive coordinator
there I mean that's what I'm doing I'm
going oh oh no sorry Kyle Shanahan I
know you're awesome and I get that but
I'm gonna make Jimmy Garoppolo beat me
and you know the Packers they are not as
talented as the 49ers but they have some
things that I do think pose some issues
for them paedon one is creative - they
have good corners on the outside and if
you really break down the 49ers offense
then the one thing that jumps out to me
Shanahan Garoppolo they live over the
middle I mean they almost throw the ball
outside the numbers or down the field
almost never I would make gyre Alexander
and Kevin King say play man-to-man play
inside technique make him throw out and
come backs and go routes we're gonna put
the other eight or nine guys right in
the middle of the field to stop all
those fancy Shanahan read-option slant
throws and play action throws over the
middle - Kittel and put all those guys
in the middle to slow down the run game
and I would play that way I think they
need to make some sort of a drastic move
like that because I mean as you know you
saw the first game you know was it a
little misleading in 37 days sure I
don't think it was that big of a blowout
but the 49ers are clearly the better
team on the field and I think the
Garofalo thing and the things we just
talked about are certainly something I
would be looking at a pop great day we
saw Odell Beckham have hundred-dollar
handshakes there at LSU how often did
you get hunter dollar handshakes at
Texas well we've had this discussion
before I've already gotten in trouble
and just so everybody okay first off it
goes on everywhere so just you know NCAA
all right nothing you could do NCA grew
up just like how the FBI takes handouts
from people who want to sponsor bowl
games players stick their hand out every
now and then and they get some cash - so
eat it I just don't know why Odell
Beckham jr. had to do it in front of the
camera okay wait only thing did you get
a phone call the last time I asked you
about this from yeah practice yeah I had
some Texas he made like called Mia more
mad at me like major you're gonna get
the school in trouble and I was like
listen you got a
the context of the conversation first
off and yeah I had to talk to the
representative from the University of
Texas they wanted to make sure it wasn't
somebody associated with the program I
was like no it happened in a parking lot
outside a restaurant twice where some
guy knew I was going into this place on
a consistent basis I came out he had
five jerseys there I signed it he gave
me like two or three hundred dollars and
I gladly accepted and moved on with life
I love you you're great
hey have a great weekend thank you buddy
a great talk to you that great talking
to you that's Chris Simms NBC sports I
didn't know I got him in trouble
I mean I'd still ask the question but
Wow for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]